I'm delighted to introduce the first guest lecturer for this introduction to
psychology course,
a dean,
Peter Salivate.
Uh,
Peter is an old friend and colleague,
many of you.
I think everybody here knows of him through his role as dean of Yale College.
Um,
I'll just in the context of this introduction mentioned two other things about
him.
One is,
um,
prior to being dean and in fact still as a dean,
he's an active scientist and in particular a social psychologist.
I'm actively involved in studying a health psychology,
the proper use of psychological methods to frame a health messages and also is
the founder and developer of the idea of emotional intelligence and ID.
He's done a huge amount of research on.
Secondly,
um,
Peter is a or was a,
an active and extremely well known teacher at Yale College.
He taught at one point the largest course ever in Yale College,
of course in psychology and law,
which broke every record ever had here.
Um,
and before that,
during that and after that he was a legendary introduction to a psychology
teacher.
And I think any at some reason for why he was so legendary with his lecture
today on the topic of love.
[inaudible]
thanks very much.
Is that okay?
Okay.
Thank you very much professor bloom.
It really is a pleasure to come and lecture to you today on Valentine's Day.
On the topic of love.
Uh,
my main area of research is human emotion and love is an emotion.
It's not one that I study personally,
at least not in the lab.
And,
um,
uh,
but it is fun to talk about and it is a,
a topic that lends itself to many social psychological phenomena.
Uh,
it's also great to be able to come in and guest lecture.
One of the things I very much miss,
uh,
since serving as Dean is the opportunity to teach psychology one 10.
And although I love being dean,
I do miss teaching introductory psychology,
uh,
the feeling of a exposing people to,
ideas that maybe you hadn't heard before.
Well,
I suspect some of the ideas in this talk you'll have not heard before.
Uh,
and for a variety of reasons.
A couple of the things you'll notice is that some of the experiments I'll talk
about today are not the kinds of experiments that can be done anymore.
They're not considered a ethically acceptable,
but they were done in the fifties and sixties and early seventies when,
uh,
ethical standards were different.
And,
um,
uh,
so we can teach them,
we just can't give you the same experiences that some of the college students,
uh,
that we'll talk about today in these studies ahead.
The other thing I will mention is that there is a certain,
um,
uh,
and Roe centric and heterosexual quality to much of the social psychological
research on romantic love.
A,
you'll see that in the experiments.
Usually the participants are men and usually the targets are,
uh,
women in these experiments.
I'm not endorsing this as the only way to study love.
It just happens to be the way these experiments were done.
And so I,
I,
I mentioned this caution,
uh,
right from the beginning.
We'll have to think about.
One of the things you should think about is do you think these experiments
generalize to other,
uh,
kinds of dyadic relationships?
Uh,
and,
uh,
that's a question that I think you can,
you,
you can ask throughout this lecture.
Okay.
So let's get started.
And to start things off,
uh,
I think what we need to do is consider a,
a definition.
I'm in a define what love is,
but then most of the experiments I'm going to talk about are really focused more
on a traction then wove who finds each other,
uh,
of romantic interest.
Um,
that might then develop into a love relationship.
But let's start with a definition of love.
And I'm going to pick a definition from a former colleague Robert Sternberg who
is now the dean at Tufts University but was here on our,
our faculty yell for nearly 30 years or so.
And uh,
he has a theory of love that argues that it's made up of three components,
intimacy,
passion and commitment or what is sometimes called decision commitment.
And these are relatively straight forward.
He argued that you don't have love if you don't have all three of these
elements.
Intimacy is the feeling of closeness,
of connectedness with someone of bonding.
Operationally,
you could think of intimacy as you share secrets.
You share information with this person that you don't share with anybody else.
Okay?
That's really what intimacy is.
The bond that comes from sharing information that isn't shared with other with
many other people.
Second,
uh,
element,
is passion.
Passion is what you think.
Uh,
it,
it is a passion is uh,
uh,
the drug.
We would say the drive that leads to romance.
You can think of it as physical attraction or sex.
And um,
Sternberg argues that this is a required component of a love relationship.
It is not,
however,
a required component of taking a shower in Calhoun college.
The third,
the third element of love in Sternberg's theory is what,
what he calls decision or commitment.
The decision that one is in a love relationship,
the willingness to label it as such,
and a commitment to maintain that relationship,
at least for some period of time.
Sternberg would argue it's not love.
If you don't call it love and if you don't have some desire to maintain the
relationship.
So if you have all three of these intimacy,
passion and commitment in Sternberg's theory,
you have love.
Now what's interesting about the theory is what do you have if you only have one
out of three or two out of three,
uh,
what,
what do you have and how is it different if you have a different two out of
three,
uh,
these are,
what's interesting about this kind of theorizing is it give,
it gives rise to many different permutations that when you break them down and
start to look at them carefully can be quite interesting.
So what I've done is I've taken a Sternberg's three elements of love,
intimacy,
passionate commitment,
and I've listed out the different kinds of relationships.
One would have if you had zero one,
two or three out of the three elements,
and I'm using names or types that Sternberg uses in his theory,
these are really from him.
Some of these are pretty obvious.
If you don't have intimacy,
if you don't have passion,
if you don't have commitment,
you don't have love.
A Sternberg calls this non love,
that's the technical term.
And um,
uh,
essentially what he's saying is the relationship you now have to the person
sitting next to you,
presuming that you're sitting next to a random person that you didn't know from
your college,
uh,
is probably non love.
If it's something else,
we can talk about it at the end of the lecture,
uh,
or perhaps when I get to it in a moment.
Now let's start to add elements.
Let's add intimacy.
This is a sharing,
uh,
secrets,
a feeling of closeness,
connectedness,
bonding.
Let's say we have that with someone,
but we don't have passion that is no sexual arousal and no commitment to
maintain the relationship.
This is liking Sternberg calls it liking and liking is really,
uh,
what is happening in most typical friendships.
Not your closest friendship,
but friendships,
uh,
of a,
of a casual kind.
You feel close,
you share certain information with that person that you don't share with other
many other people,
but you're not physically attractive.
And there's no particular commitment to maintaining this for a long period of
time.
Now,
what if you're not in a minute,
you're not committed,
but you're passionate.
You feel that sexual arousal,
this is what a Starbuck would call infatuation.
And that term probably works for you too.
Infatuated,
love.
And uh,
this is love at first sight.
I don't know you,
we've never shared any secrets because I don't know you.
I'm not,
I'm not committed to defining this as anything.
I'm not committed to the future.
In fact,
I'm not thinking about the future.
I'm thinking about right now.
But boy,
am I attracted.
All right.
That's,
that's,
that's infatuation.
And that's what Sternberg means by infatuated love.
The third kind of one element relationship.
If there's no intimacy,
right?
No bonding,
no closest,
no secrets,
no physical attraction,
no sexual arousal.
But by Gosh,
we are going to maintain this relationship.
We are committed to it,
uh,
for all time.
Starbuck calls that empty love,
empty love is kind of interesting.
Um,
it's often the final stage of longterm relationships that have gone bad.
We don't share information with each other anymore.
So there's no intimacy.
We don't feel physically attracted to each other anymore.
There's no passion,
but we better stay together for the kids,
right?
Or We'd better stay together for appearances sake.
We better stay together because financially it would be a disaster if we don't,
or all of the reasons other than intimacy and passion that people might commit
to each other.
That's what Sternberg calls empty love.
Now,
what's interesting is in societies where marriages are arranged,
this is often the first stage of a,
of a love relationship.
These two people who've maybe never seen each other before,
who have never shared secrets,
so there's no intimacy who have never,
I don't know if they're physically attracted to each other or on their wedding
day revealed to each other and committed legally and sometimes religiously,
uh,
to each other,
right?
The commitment is there,
but at that moment,
nothing else might be there.
What's interesting of course,
is that such relationships don't seem to have any greater chance of ending in
divorce then people who marry for love,
but there's a big con found,
there's a big problem in studies of those kind of relationships.
What might it be?
Anybody,
what might be the problem in the statement I just made that these kind of
relationships are just as likely to survive as people who married for love.
Yes.
Yeah.
So they,
the,
they may occur,
they're more likely to occur in societies that frown on divorce,
that make it very costly,
uh,
socially costly,
to divorce.
So they may stay together for all kinds of reasons.
Not always such good ones.
All right.
Now,
um,
who was it?
Who has it?
Who Sang the song?
Uh,
two out of three a bed.
Does that meat loaf,
who was it?
It was meatloaf fight.
Preferably if professor bloom says it was Meatloaf,
it was meatloaf.
You're all saying there was a sailor called meatloaf.
Meatloaf sang the song.
Two out of three ain't bad.
Let's see if two out of three,
eight bad.
What if you have,
uh,
intimacy?
We share secrets,
passion.
We feel physically attracted to each other,
but we're not making any commitments here.
Starboard calls that romantic love.
This is a physical attraction with close bonding,
but no commitment.
Romeo and Juliet when they first met.
Uh,
this is often the way relationships a start.
We like each other.
I'm physically attracted to each other.
I tell you,
I enjoy spending time with you,
but I'm not making any long term commitment so I'm not even willing to use the l
word in describing what it is we have,
right?
Many of you might've been in relationships of this sort.
That's,
that's romance,
that's romantic glove.
Now what have you have?
Intimacy.
We share,
uh,
secrets with each other,
but there's no particular physical attraction,
but we are really committed to this relationship.
This is what Sternberg coast companion at love.
This is your best friend.
We are committed to sharing intimacy,
to be friends forever,
but physical attraction is not part of the equation here.
This is sort of the,
uh,
maybe the Greek ideal,
in,
uh,
relationships of some kind.
All right?
What if we have passion?
I'm sexually attracted to you,
but no intimacy.
I don't want to really know that much about you.
I don't really,
really share anything of me with you,
but I am committed to maintaining this physical attraction to you.
Well,
that's uh,
what Sternberg calls fatuous love.
It's a whirlwind courtship.
It's a Hollywood romance.
It might lead to a shotgun wedding.
Maybe you find yourself in Las Vegas and you get married for a day and a half.
And uh,
and then realize that this wasn't such a good idea.
And maybe your name is Brittany and you're a singer.
Well,
anyway,
you got the,
okay,
you got the idea.
Uh,
that's,
that's fatuous love.
Uh,
we are,
we are basically committed to each other for sex,
but it's very hard to make those relationships last a long time because we might
not have anything in common.
We might not share anything with each other.
We might not trust each other.
We're not particularly bonded to each other.
On the other hand,
if you have all three NMSC passion,
commitment,
this is consummate love according to starboard complete love.
This is how he defines love.
Okay?
So now you have a definition of love and you can now as a homework assignment,
uh,
sit down tonight and make a list of every person you know by the three elements
of love and just start putting the check marks in the boxes and tallying up your
personal love box score.
And uh,
we don't want to collect those.
We don't even want to see those.
But um,
you can have fun with that.
Then you can ask the other people to do it too and you can compare with each
other.
And uh,
you know,
if you all survive this exercise,
you'll be better for it.
You know,
what doesn't kill you makes you stronger.
That's the idea behind that exercise.
All right,
now the social psychology of love really has been a social psychology of
attraction.
What makes people find each other attractive?
What makes them want to be intimate?
What makes them physically desirable to each other?
What might lead to a commitment,
a decision to make,
a commitment to make the relationship last.
This is just so nice.
I'm giving this lecture on love and the two of you are holding hands here in
the,
in the front row.
It's really
all three elements present,
intimacy,
passion and yeah.
Okay.
Just checking.
So what's interesting about the social psychology of attraction is it as focused
on seven variables and I've divided these into two groups,
the big three and the more interesting for,
and I call them the big,
the big three are three variables that the effects are so powerful that they
almost don't need to be discussed in much detail.
The more interesting for the ones I'm going to focus on in this lecture because
there are a bit more subtle and uh,
they may be a thing that you've never heard of before,
but let's quickly talk about the three.
The way to understand the big three is with the phrase all other things being
equal,
all other things being equal.
People who find themselves in clothes,
spatial proximity to each other,
like sharing an armrest in a lecture.
Uh,
we'll be,
we'll be more likely to be attracted to each other and form a romantic
relationship.
Okay.
All other things being equal.
Now this has been tested in lots of interesting ways.
Studies have been done in the city of New York where you can,
if you live in Manhattan,
you can actually get a very nice metric of how far apart people live from each
other in city blocks,
right?
You have a nice grid pattern and you can use a city block metric to,
to uh,
add up the number of blocks between people's stores and people who live more
closely together are more likely to end up in romantic relationships with each
other.
It seems kind of obvious,
right?
Uh,
this even works on college campuses.
We can measure in feet the distance between the door to your room and the door
to every other room of a student on campus.
And there will be a correlation between the likelihood of a negative
correlation,
the likelihood of getting into a romantic relationship with a person and the
number of feet between your door and that person's door.
The fewer feet,
the more likely a romantic relationship,
all other things being equal.
Now,
all other things being equal is a big qualifier,
right?
But if we can statistically control for every other variable,
all I'd need to do is measure the distance from your door to everybody else's
door on campus.
And I could chart out who's going to fall in love with whom,
uh,
on the yell a campus.
Now this idea,
uh,
in a way,
um,
is,
uh,
I don't know,
maybe it's a little counter intuitive.
There's a kind of cultural myth around the,
uh,
the stranger,
the person you don't know who you,
uh,
will,
who you fall in love with.
And that is not likely to be the case if it's the person who's nearby.
Right?
And you'll see as we go through the other big thing,
the other two big three,
uh,
that,
there's a,
uh,
a kind of repetition of this theme.
It isn't the stranger you fall in love with.
All right,
let's continue down similarity.
You've probably heard the phrase birds of a feather flock together.
And that's true when it comes to romance on any dimension that psychologists
have measured in these kinds of studies.
When people are more similar,
they are more likely to find each other,
uh,
attractive.
This could be obvious things like height or age,
but it also could be things like attitudes toward capital punishment,
preference for the red sox over the Yankees,
right?
All of these are dimensions of similarity.
All things being equal,
the more similar,
the more likely you'll find each other attractive.
So opposites don't really attract birds of a flight.
Feather may flock together,
but opposites don't really track.
Don't really attract each other.
Now,
usually at this point,
somebody in the lecture hall raises their hand and says,
well,
my boyfriend or my girlfriend and I are complete opposites.
And how do you account for that?
Professor salivate.
And I usually look at them and I say,
good luck.
And of course all things might not be equal.
There may be other variables at play here,
but all day team equal similarity,
uh,
does not breed contempt.
Similarity breeds attraction.
Okay.
Is it an interesting,
we have all of these common sayings that contradict each other and then
empirically,
some of them turn out to have more evidence supporting them than others.
So opposites attract not much evidence.
Similarity breeds contempt.
Not much evidence.
Birds of a feather flock together.
Yeah,
there's some evidence for that idea.
Finally,
familiarity.
Familiarity.
We tend to fall in love with people in our environment with whom we are already
familiar.
We,
uh,
the idea that some enchanted evening we will see a stranger.
Where are the new blue when you need them?
Uh,
some enchanted evening you will see a stranger across a crowded room.
Alright?
What musical is that from South Pacific?
Very good.
You'll see a stranger across a crowded room.
That's,
that's kind of a cultural myth.
Of course it happens,
but much more common is somebody who already know somebody who have seen
repetitively,
you suddenly find a traction,
attractive,
and a relationship forms.
Okay.
So,
uh,
the big three people who are similar to you,
people who are already familiar to you,
people who are nearby in space,
these are the people,
all things being equal that you will find attractive.
Okay?
So those are the big three.
Those are big main effects.
Those are big,
uh,
easy to observe in various ways in the lab.
By the way,
the familiarity idea doesn't just work for people.
I can show you words in a language that you don't speak and I can flash those
words,
do you very quickly and I can later repeat some of those words and mix and some
new ones that you've never seen before.
And I can say,
I don't know.
I know you don't know what any of these words mean.
I know you can't read these characters,
but just if you had to tell me which ones do you like and which ones don't you
like or how much do you like each one?
The ones who will like more.
The ones who saw earlier,
the ones that you already have familiarity.
Even if you don't remember having seen them,
even if that familiarity was generated with such quick exposures that you don't
remember even having seen anything,
you will get that familiarity effect.
Okay,
good.
The more interesting for these are more interesting because they're a little bit
complicated,
a little bit subtle.
Let's start with actually the one that is my favorite.
This is competence.
Think about other people in your environment.
Think about people who are competent generally and think about people who are
incompetent.
Generally we are more attracted to people who seem competent to us.
Now that isn't very interesting and it turns out that's not really the effect.
Yes,
we're more attracted to people who are competent than people would think are
incompetent.
But people who are super competent,
people who seem competent on all dimensions,
they're kind of threatening to us.
That'll make us feel so good about ourselves,
right?
They,
they make us feel a bit diminished by comparison.
So what we really like,
the kind of person we're really attracted to is the competent individual who
occasionally blunders,
and this is called the pratfall effect that are liking for the competent person
grows when they make a mistake,
when they do something embarrassing,
when they have a failure experience.
Okay.
You can see this with public figures,
public figures who are viewed as competent,
but who prat fall,
who make a mistake?
Sometimes they're even more popular after the mistake.
Okay.
I think of,
uh,
Bill Clinton when he was president,
his popularity at the end of his term,
despite what everyone would agree with you,
like Bill Clinton or not,
was a big mistake with Monica Lewinsky.
His popularity.
He didn't suffer very much.
A lot of people in the media would describe him.
Well,
he's just,
it just shows he's human.
He makes mistakes like the rest of us,
even though that was pretty big mistake.
Right?
And you can see this even with smaller pratfalls,
sometimes public figures or liked even more after their platform.
Now,
the classic experiment,
the classic pratfall experiment is just a beautiful one to describe it.
It's a work of art.
So let me tell you a little bit about your,
in this experiment you're brought for the lab and you're listening to a tape
recording of interviews with people who are described as possible
representatives from your college to appear on a quiz show.
Uh,
the quiz show is called college ball,
which I don't think is on anymore,
but was on when I was in college.
And you're listening to interviews with possible contestants from Yale who are
going to be on college level.
You have to decide how much,
uh,
what you're told is you have to decide who should be chosen to be on college
ball.
And you listen to these interviews.
Now what's interesting is there's two types of people.
The nearly perfect person and the mediocre person,
the nearly perfect person answered 92% of the questions correctly admitted
modestly to being a member of the campus.
Honor Society was the editor of the yearbook and Wa and ran varsity track.
That's the nearly perfect person.
The mediocre person answers only 30% of the questions correctly.
Uh,
and myths that he has only average grades.
He worked on the yearbook as a proofreader and he tried out for the track team
but didn't make it.
So you see,
they're keeping a lot of the elements consistent.
But in one case,
he's kind of an average performer and the other case nearly perfect.
Now,
which of these two people do you find more attractive in listening to the tape?
So when they ask you questions about which person should be on the quiz show,
people say the more competent person,
but they also ask questions like,
how attractive do you find this person?
Now you're only listening to an audio tape.
How attractive do you find this person?
And the results are pretty obvious.
They're competent person is rated as much more attractive,
considerably more attractive than the mediocre person.
Okay?
If this were the end of the story though,
it would be a kind of boring story and it's not the end of the story.
Now,
what happens is half of the participants in the experiment who have listened to
each of these tapes,
you only get to listen to one take.
Half of them are assigned to the blunder condition.
And what happens in the blundered condition is the tape continues.
And what you hear is the clattering of dishes.
Uh,
a person saying,
the person saying,
oh my goodness,
I've spilled coffee all over my new suit.
Okay,
that's the blender.
That's the Prat Fall.
Now you're asked,
who do you find more attractive?
And look what happens?
Your rating of the attractiveness of the competent person grows even higher.
The carbon and person who blunders,
this is the person that I love.
Unfortunately the mediocre person who blunders you now think is even more
mediocre.
This is the sad irony in these experiments.
The effect works both ways.
So the mediocre become even more lowered in your esteem and your regard.
Now I'll tell you a little personal story about my coming to yell that that
relates to this experiment.
This is one of the most famous experiments in the history of social psychology.
I wouldn't quite put it up there.
You'll care maybe later about mill or maybe you've already about Milgrom and,
and maybe asch conformity and maybe robber's cave.
Those are even better than,
than this,
but this is right up there.
This is a top five experiment.
What?
Um,
so,
uh,
and it was done by Elliot Aronson who has retired now,
but for many years taught at the University of California.
Santa Cruz name is not one that you need to know.
In any case.
I came to yell in 1981 is a graduate student and I was looking for an advisor
and I was kind of interviewing with a faculty member at yell at the time named
Judy Roden.
Some of you may know that name because she went on later to become the president
of the University of Pennsylvania and now as the president of the Rockefeller
Foundation.
But I was interviewing with her.
I've had it set up a meeting and what I was trying to persuade her in this
meeting was to take me on as one of her students to let to be my advisor.
And it's about my third or fourth week of graduate school and I'm pretty nervous
about this.
And uh,
you know,
she could be intimidating to a first year graduate student.
And I remember I was holding this Mug of coffee and I was pleading with her,
trying to convince her to take me on as her student.
I was saying,
Judy,
all,
I'll get a lot done.
I'll work really hard.
All I can analyze data I can write,
you know what I'm talking about myself.
And I'm sad.
I'm swinging,
I'm using my hands as I talk.
I'm swinging this cup of coffee around and um,
fairly uh,
sued into the conversation.
I demonstrated some principle that you've probably learned in your physics class
having to do with an object at rest remaining at rest unless acted upon by a
force.
Well,
the object at rest was the coffee in the cup.
And when I pulled the Coffee Cup out from under the coffee,
it landed right on her desk and began,
I've watched in slow motion as this wave of coffee just moved from my side of
the desk to her side of the desk.
She jumped up and jumped back and started moving papers around and really was
giving me this look like,
why don't you just leave?
So I was trying to save the moment as best as I could.
And I looked there and I said,
uh,
Judy,
you remember old experiment that Elliot Aronson did on attractiveness?
She looked at me kind of out of the corner of ride.
I said,
well,
that was my blunder.
Now you're going to like me even more.
And she just shook her head and she said,
Peter,
you know,
that affect only works if I think you're competent first.
Anyway,
that was my introduction to Yale graduate school.
Yep.
All right.
So blundering blundering only blender if you're competent,
uh,
first,
and it will make you more attractive.
That is the,
the pratfall effect.
Let's move on and I'm,
I'm gonna move a little bit quickly through all of this because I want to leave
time for a few questions at the end of the lecture.
Uh,
let's talk about physical attractiveness as number two of the more interesting.
For now,
physical attractiveness is one that really bothers us.
We don't like to believe that physical attractiveness accounts for much in life.
It seems unfair except at the margins.
There isn't much we can do about physical attractiveness.
And when we're not pictured in the rumpus,
it can really hurt,
you know,
the,
uh,
so we don't like to believe that physical attractiveness matters.
And the interesting thing is if you do surveys of college students and you say
to them,
rate how important different characteristics are in relationships that you might
be involved in,
they will say that warmth is important,
sensitivity isn't important.
Intelligence is important.
Compassion is important.
Sense of humor is important,
and they'll say that looks aren't important,
but if you measure all of those things,
let's do it it in different order.
If you send everybody out on a blind date,
okay,
and then you look at after the blind date,
how many of those people who are matched up blindly actually go on a second
date,
actually get together again?
What predicts who gets together?
Again,
was it the rating of warmth?
No sensitivity,
no intelligence,
no compassion,
no sense of humor,
no.
What was it looks so we believe that looks don't matter.
And unfortunately they do.
Now the good news in all of this is the studies that looked at physical
attractiveness in this way.
We're just looking at what predicts a date after a first date.
Obviously what predicts a longterm relationship are probably things less
superficial,
uh,
than look.
So at least other things in addition to looks,
but it is a great predictor of a second date and college students year after
year say,
but it's not important and it's one of those classic dissociation between what
we think is an important and what empirically turns out to be more important.
All right.
Well they're very interesting studies that have been done with physical
attractiveness at the University of Minnesota.
Uh,
a computer algorithm paired people up.
I couldn't have been a very complicated algorithm because it basically paired
people up randomly,
uh,
on the campus,
but the computer,
but a lot of data about all the students on campus were color was collected,
were collected and uh,
uh,
people were then randomly paired up and sent to the dance and then they were
tracked over time.
And just as in the thought experiment I just gave you,
the University of Minnesota students acted in the same way.
If the computer,
if they rated their partner as attractive,
uh,
the,
the randomly assigned partner,
they were more likely to continue the relationship.
Now,
it's interesting to ask why and we have to start to look at other experiments to
try to get at what is it about physical attractiveness that,
um,
uh,
makes people want to pursue the relationship.
And once again,
Elliot Aronson,
the person who,
uh,
did the blunder experiment,
the pratfall experiment,
he did some nice work on a track then this as well.
And it wasn't what experiment,
which many people know is the frizzy wig experiment.
He did the following.
He,
he invited a,
uh,
a confederate,
a graduate sooner who was working with him in his lab,
psychologist,
social psychologist,
always called people who were in the employ of the experimenter,
confederates.
It doesn't mean that they grew up south of the Mason Dixon line or a wave a
wave,
a certain kind of flag.
Uh,
but the older term for it was stooge.
They would say,
we,
we've hired a stooge to act in the following role in the experiment.
But I think a certain generation of college students thought stooge stooges were
only named moe,
Larry and curly.
And so they,
uh,
they,
they started to this phrase confederate.
Now,
they'll usually just say,
we hired an actor now.
Anyway,
their confederate that they hired was a woman who is naturally attractive in
most people's view,
but they made her look either more attractive or less attractive by,
uh,
giving her kind of frumpy clothes,
bad makeup,
and a frizzy wake.
And it was the frizzy wig that everybody remembers from this experiment at what
she does in the experiment.
And she poses as a graduate student in clinical psychology who is interviewing
male participants,
only men in this experiment.
And at the end of the interview,
she gives them her own personal clinical evaluation of their personality.
Okay.
So that's all it is to have this interview with this woman.
She's either made to look very good or she's made to look a kind of ugly with
this frizzy wig.
And they talked to her.
She gives them an evaluation of their personality.
Half of the subjects received a favorable personality assessment.
Half of them receive a kind of unfavorable evaluation.
How do they respond?
Well when she was made to look attractive,
they were delighted when she gave them positive feedback about themselves once
she was made to look,
when she gave,
when she was made to look attractive,
but gave them unfavorable information about themselves,
they were really upset about it.
When she was made to look unattractive.
They didn't really care what kind of information she gave.
It didn't really matter whether it was positive or not.
It didn't really make any difference.
It was interesting in the condition where she was made to look attractive,
but gave you bad feedback about yourself.
Often the subjects in that condition,
we'd look for an opportunity to interact with her in the future.
Obviously to try to prove that her evaluation was wrong,
it mattered that much to them.
So there's kind of this idea that attractive people,
their feedback to us has more impact.
I'm not saying this is fair,
I'm not saying it's rational.
I'm not endorsing it,
but empirically,
excuse me,
empirically we can see it.
It's somehow the attractive,
the feedback from the attractive person matters.
Uh,
more uh,
to us.
Okay.
Number three of the more interesting for gain loss.
This is really a general idea in psychology that we are in a way wired up to be
more sensitive,
to change then to steady states.
And you could imagine why that might be true.
Change often signals danger or opportunity.
And if we are especially tuned in to change,
uh,
it,
it helps us survive and it helps us pass along our genes.
Okay,
so we're more sensitive to change.
How does that play out in love?
Well,
in love,
uh,
we are in what is very powerful to us is not just that someone always is
positive toward us.
I love you,
I love you.
I love right.
It wears out.
It's welcome.
What's more powerful is the person who was not that positive to us,
but over time becomes more positive.
The first derivative of their regard for us is positive.
Okay.
Aronson calls this the gain effect.
We are really attracted to people whose regard for us is gaining momentum over
time.
Okay.
And even if over a period of time the average amount of their regard is lower
because they started lower and then got higher than someone who was always high.
It's the ones who are first lower who then went up that capture our attention.
The first derivative is more important than just the position of their regard
for us getting better and better.
Now what's interesting is there's also a loss affect.
People who really hurt us are not the people who have always been negative.
The president who every time they seize you hates you,
it says they hate you and a company's it with an obscene gesture.
After a while,
this person can't hurt you,
right?
There's a,
there's a country song that Ricky Skaggs sings that has the phrasing it.
Nothing can hurt you like the person you love.
That's what hurts the prison who always was positive,
who's now,
who's regard starts to fade.
You can only hurt the one you love,
right?
You can only hurt the one you love because you are expecting positive feedback
from the one you love and when that turns negative,
it's,
it's a blow.
It's a blow to the solar plexus,
right?
So you can only hurt the one you can love.
But the one who always loves you sometimes has trouble showing you that they
love you,
the one who didn't really love you that much.
But then she starts to show you that they love you.
That person is a powerful influence on your,
uh,
behavior.
Okay.
Low last,
whoops,
come back.
The last set of studies
have you talked about chapters?
Singers,
emotion.
Okay.
So let me,
let me describe to you this phenomenon.
This is a phenomenon,
uh,
about the miss attribution for the causes of arousal.
You feel physiologically aroused,
but you're not completely sure why and you have to make up an explanation for
it.
I think what I want to do,
and sometimes that explanation is accurate,
but the ones that are interesting here are the ones where you misattribute the
cause of the arousal.
You make a mistake and think it's love when it might be due to something else.
So let's do a thought experiment.
I'm a gay male college student for the purposes of this thought experiment.
And I live in Pearson because I need to walk a great distance to Chapel Street,
to the Starbucks on Chapel Street.
And I have a friend who,
I don't know that well,
somebody who was sitting next to me in class a few weeks in a row.
And I said,
you know,
would you like to go see the new blue in concert and then get coffee after it
Friday night?
And she says to me,
sure that I would do that.
And so the new blue concert takes place in the Pearson Davenport Theater in the
basement there,
what used to be a squash court and is now a little theater.
And we enjoy ourselves at the concert.
And then I say,
let's go to Starbucks and get a coffee.
And so we walk that distance from Pearson College,
uh,
down to the York street gate over to Chapel Street.
Nick the left on Chapel Street,
another block down to high walk into the Starbucks.
And she says to me,
you know,
I better have a decaf because,
uh,
it's title late.
I want to be able to sleep.
And I say,
that's fine.
Whatever you want.
She says,
yes,
I'll have a DECAF double expressor Mocha skinny with a what?
What other dimensions are there?
Right.
A Double Espresso or Mocha skinny frost.
And I say,
okay,
fine.
I'll have a coffee and a,
I go up there and I ordered the drinks.
I'll have a car,
a small coffee please.
And a double espresso or Mocha skinny [inaudible] except the Barista makes a
mistake that the word Barrista exists before Starbucks.
I don't think so.
The Barista makes a mistake.
The Barista uses caffeinated coffee in the drink instead of DECAF.
Doesn't tell anybody.
Doesn't tell me.
I don't see it.
I just come back with my black coffee and my double espresso or Mocha Latte,
skinny frost,
except it isn't expresso.
It's got two shots of caffeinated and specimen.
I'm sorry it isn't decaffeinated.
It's got two shots of caffeinated espresso in it and I put it down on the table
and we're having this nice conversation and we're drinking our beverages and
it's about 1231 o'clock now and Starbucks is closing and it's time to walk back
to Pearson.
When we're walking back to Pearson and when we leave this Starbucks,
we make a left on chapel street.
We're walking up to York.
I'm getting a little sleepy,
but my friend looks at me and says,
Huh,
I feel a little funny.
What's actually happening?
Our heart is beating a little faster.
Okay.
Her POVs are beginning to sweat.
Her breath is coming a little shorter than it otherwise would.
I Dunno.
Right?
Said warm in here.
I don't think I've felt this way in a very long time.
No,
couldn't be the coffee I ordered.
Decas what could this be?
What?
Then she turns and she looks at me
and she says,
what a day this has been.
What are rare booed?
I'm in.
Why?
It's almost like being in love.
It is almost like being love except what it really is is two shots of
caffeinated espresso
causing a rapid heart rate,
a decrease in respiration,
sweaty palms,
but I don't realize she doesn't realize that's what it is.
She turns to the most salient or this is the way social psychologists would say.
It turns to the most salient object in her immediate social environment that
that would be me and says she's in love.
That's the idea of misattribution arouse due to something else.
Don't know what that is.
It's best if you don't know what that is.
Or even if you do mistakenly attributed mis,
attributed,
uh,
to physical attraction,
romance,
intimacy,
passion and commitment.
It's love.
All right.
Now,
uh,
I don't necessarily recommend that you do this thought experiment,
in,
uh,
in Vivo,
this weekend.
Uh,
although if you're lonely,
you might want to try it.
But,
um,
we can go,
we can take this idea,
right?
Uh,
we can,
we can actually do a search on this.
We could take it into the lab.
But before I tell you about lab experiments,
let me tell about the most famous field experiment on this idea.
We call this the rickety bridge experiment.
And there's a bridge at the University of British Columbia,
uh,
that crosses a river that runs through campus and the rickety,
there's actually two bridges.
The rickety bridge is one that's kind of a rope bridge.
It's hundreds of feet above the river.
It's ways in the breeze.
It's only about three feet wide.
You kind of hold on to it carefully and you crossed the river.
It's pretty scary to cross that river.
Does anybody bit been seeing this bridge?
It's still there?
Yes.
You know there's bridge.
Okay.
There's another way to cross the river.
It's on us.
Low Bridge near the water,
solid wood planks,
nice and wide,
uh,
hand railings made out of solid wood and you can cross the bridge that way.
So what a two investigators at the University of British Columbia did is they
simply positioned,
uh,
once again,
man,
attractive,
uh,
actor or confederate,
on one side of the bridge she was a woman and she met men crossing the bridge
and she would intercept them as they came across the rickety bridge or the low
bridge and she would ask them a few questions and conclude with,
can you write me a story?
Just it would help me out with my experiment if you just write a little story
right now.
Then she would collect this story and she would say,
if you have any questions about this experiment,
here's my phone number.
Actually this happens when you're an experiments.
You get the phone number of the experiment.
What happens?
Well,
the men,
male students who crossed the rickety bridge,
they wrote these sexy stories with interesting content,
with kind of a,
uh,
kind of,
um,
little bit reibel themes.
And the people are the Rick on the solid bridge.
He just wrote pretty boring stories.
The people who crossed the rickety bridge,
we're more likely to call her up later and say,
yeah,
I'd like to talk about that experiment.
I was in a,
can we meet at the Starbucks?
Uh,
you drink decaf,
don't you write the,
uh,
and the people on the low bridge were much less likely to call her up.
Okay.
The eye,
what was going on?
Well,
what this was interpreted as miss attributed arousal on the rickety bridge.
You're swaying in the breeze hundreds of feet above the water.
The bridge seems unstable.
Maybe you'll make it,
maybe you won't.
Your heart is beating yours.
Palms are sweating.
You're breathing harder.
You meet this person and uh,
she seems more attractive because you're feeling all these things and you
attribute it to,
to the attraction.
Now,
there's a reason why this study is bad science.
There's a major flaw in this study.
The clue to the flaw is that you can't even call this study and experiment.
What's the flaw?
Anybody?
Yes?
People who take the rickety bridge might be the kind of people who are more
looking for adventure.
Uh,
then the people who take the solid bridge,
right?
Another way of saying it is there isn't random
of the subjects to the two conditions in the,
in the study.
That's no random assignment.
It's not an experiment.
You by not randomly assigning people to these two conditions,
you may be capturing just individual differences in the kind of person who,
when there's a perfectly stable,
safe,
low bridge.
So it's,
ah,
I don't want to go on that bridge.
I want to go on the Bridgeway after risk by life that get the class
and then should it surprise us that that's the kind of person who would call a
perfect stranger on the telephone and write a sexy story and give it to them,
right?
We're not so surprised.
So what we have to do of course is take it into the lab and do this in a more
systematic way with random assignment.
And this is how I want to finish up.
Uh,
today we have til to til uh,
two 45,
three 45.
Okay,
great.
I'll,
I'll take about five more minutes to finish up and now they'll give us some time
for questions.
So how do you do this in the lab?
Well,
you can bring people into the lab and I can present you with a confederate who
says,
let's say you are all in condition one.
Everybody on this side of the room.
And I can say to all of you,
please wait here.
We'll begin the experiment in a moment.
While you're waiting,
please fill out this form.
And the form includes how attractive,
how attracted you are to the experiment.
To me,
I can do the same thing over here.
I can say,
I can give you the form that asks you to rate how attractive you think I am and
I can give you the same instruction where the crucial difference.
Please wait.
Here
we will begin the painful shock experiment in a moment.
Please fill out these forms.
By the way,
what happens to people who got the painful shock instruction are more likely to
find the confederate attractive.
Why?
Well,
they're sitting there thinking about painful shock.
It's making their heartbeat faster.
It's making their palms sweat.
It's making them breathe harder maybe.
And even though it's fairly obvious what's doing that,
they still miss attribute that arousal too.
I must be falling in love even with that obvious a,
uh,
even with that obvious and instruction,
you can do this in other ways.
You can bring here,
here,
here's one of my favorite ones.
You bring people in the lab.
Let's,
we'll,
we'll make them the control group.
This time we bring you in to the lab and we say to this group of people,
please wait here.
We'll begin the experiment in a moment.
Can fill out these forms.
In the meantime,
the forums ask how you are to the experimenter.
You're now in the experimental group and I say,
please,
uh,
wait here.
We'll begin to experiment a moment.
Uh,
I'm going to ask you to fill out some forms,
but first to get ready for this experiment,
I'd like you to get on this treadmill and run for 10 minutes.
So you've run on the treadmill,
you've just sat around the people who run on the treadmill,
even when that,
that arousal is fairly obvious,
you've got,
you do worry a little bit of aerobics exercise,
you still find
the experimenter more attractive.
Okay?
This is why the fourth floor of Payne Whitney Jim is such a dangerous place and
I urge you as your dean to be very careful there.
It's that combination of aerobic exercise and SPANDEX
leads to trouble.
All right?
Now here's the final experiment,
and I apologize for this.
It is a bit sexist in uh,
2007 context.
But let me explain it.
And we could never do this one,
could never do this experiment today,
but let me,
let me,
let me go through it with you and you'll apologize for its,
um,
uh,
some of its qualities in this experiment.
Male subjects were brought into the lab and then were asked to look at
centerfolds from Playboy magazine.
So these are essentially photographs of naked women
and they are wearing headphones that amplify their heartbeat and they are asked
among other things,
how attracted are they to the centerfold photograph that they're looking at?
This maybe,
I don't remember how many they look at.
Maybe it's about 10.
So these slides are coming up.
They've got the headphones on,
the headphones are amplifying their heartbeat and the slides are moving one
after another for a few seconds each slide,
and they're listening to their heartbeat.
Slide one
slide to
slide three,
slide four,
slide five,
slide six.
And then they're asked which one did you find most attractive?
Uh,
which one are you most attracted to?
Oh,
slide five.
Absolutely.
Uh,
she's,
she's the woman I want to marry.
And what has happened is they're using this bodily Q of their heartbeat to infer
that that's who they find more attractive.
Now here's the twist.
They're not actually listening to their heartbeat.
They're listening to a tape recording of a heartbeat and experimenter is back
there with the speed knob and at random intervals,
he just speeds up the tape of their heart
and then just slows it down again.
And it doesn't matter which slide he speeds up the tape of the heartbeat on.
That's the one the subject is more likely to think is,
uh,
the person of their dreams,
a person they're attracted to.
So even you can miss a tribute,
real arousal.
You can even miss a tribute,
phony arousal arousal that isn't even coming from your body that's just coming,
that's just,
it's just been played to you randomly.
You can even miss attribute that.
Okay.
I think these experiments are cute and I think there's an interesting phenomena
there.
And it says something in a way about how easily we can be misled as to what
things in our environment,
even things coming from our own body,
me.
But there's also some very serious implications of this kind of work.
One of them has to do with domestic violence,
so think about domestic violence situations and why people stay in them.
Why do people stay in relationships that are violent now?
The number one reason,
and we have to acknowledge it up front,
is usually economically there's no alternative p or people believe there's no
alternative.
I can't leave because if I leave,
I'd be homeless.
If I leave,
I will starve.
If my lead,
if I leave,
my kids will starve or there'll be danger to my kids.
And that keeps people trapped in abusive relationships,
but,
and that's number one.
But what else might be going on?
Sometimes people don't realize that the relationship there ein is abusive.
It's psychologically or emotionally abusive.
They get into these fights and screaming matches and name calling and such.
Even if it's not physical violence and they feel a certain arousal when that
happens and they miss a tribute it to,
well,
he wouldn't be yelling and screaming at me if he didn't love me.
Right.
They misattribute that,
that what might be anger,
what might even be aggression and violence to an expression of love.
I have a friend who's a social psychologist who told me a story once that you
know,
that,
that really,
uh,
really,
maybe very nervous,
although she's fine.
She said,
when I was dating my husband,
this is 30 years ago,
um,
we were having a tough time.
We were in many,
many arguments.
We got into many,
many arguments and one time something happened where he came up to my car in a
parking lot and he was yelling at me through the window and I rolled up the
window and before you know it,
he had punched out the window and you know,
you know,
yelling at her,
punched out the window.
He didn't touch her and he,
she said to me,
that's when I knew he really loved me and I thought,
that's scary.
All joking aside,
that's scary,
you know,
but that's mis attributed arousal.
I'm feeling when he did that,
I felt something and I assumed it was love.
What she was miss attributed as love.
Well she was misattributing his aggressive response as love.
She was miss attributing her own fear as mutual attraction is.
And I must love him,
you know,
so,
uh,
although we joke about these kinds of experiments and they are fun to talk about
because they are a unusual and um,
uh,
and cute.
There was also some serious implications of this kind of work,
uh,
that one might think about and you might think about other possible implications
as well.
Okay.
Let me stop there and see what kinds of questions we might have.
Thank you.
Thanks very much.
That's very kind of you.
Uh,
because we are on tape,
I'll repeat any questions that come in.
Yup.
That's where the painful shopping experiment.
Yeah.
Did you not say that if you're,
if you were informed that this experiment include painful shops,
you're not raising the experiment or higher because,
right.
So the question is spam.
It's like the painful shock expand experiment.
If you're told in advance like you all,
are you through a consent form or by the expenditure,
this is an experiment involving painful shock.
Will you still rate the experimenter is more attractive or will you not be able
to miss a tribute?
The arousal,
it is true.
The more salient we make,
the source of the arousal,
the less likely you can get the effect.
If in my thought experiment,
I say to my friend,
well,
I know why you're feeling that way.
The reason why you're feeling that way is because the Barista made a mistake and
gave you caffeinated espresso when you asked for decaf.
Or maybe you just love me,
right?
The person is not likely to say,
oh,
I bet it's love.
They're more likely to think,
oh,
caffeine.
Yeah.
That's the puzzle.
Ammonia's explanation here.
So it is through.
The more sales you'll make the cause of the arousal,
the less likely you'll get the effect.
But you can see even experiments where the cause of the arousal is somewhat
obvious,
at least to us.
You can still get a miss a trip.
Misattribution affect other questions.
Yes.
Okay.
Yeah.
So the question is,
are any of these factors,
like particularly the big three,
a proximity familiarities similarity,
do they affect the maintenance of relationships or just the initial attraction?
You know,
it's interesting.
My guess is they affect both initial and and maintenance over time.
But the literature mostly focuses on initial attraction.
Yeah.
Much richer data on that initial attraction in those initial stages of the
relationship.
In part because it's a little hard to follow couples over time and imagine,
imagine the,
uh,
the sort of Heisenberg ask problems.
We would get carefully following romantic couples over time and an interfering
with them to,
uh,
you know,
probe and ask questions and,
and,
uh,
make observations.
It'd be hard to let this couple naturally this relationship naturally unfold.
So we really get,
so really the focus of many of these experiments is on initial attraction.
That's why I always say my,
my lecture is on love.
The definition of terms is about love,
but the experiments really are much more about attraction then about about love.
No other questions?
Yes.
Oh,
can someone feel consummate love for more than one person?
Very good question.
It's actually a question that's debated in the literature.
I didn't get into it at all and this experiment in this lecture,
but there's an interesting debate going on about love and many other emotions,
uh,
between people who would take a kind of evolutionary perspective on these states
versus people who take what might be called a more socially constructed a
prospective.
And these aren't necessarily so incompatible.
But the evolutionary perspective I think would argue that you can feel like I've
kind of love for more than one person,
or at least it would facilitate the passing on of your genetic material to a
larger array of the next generation.
You know?
So I think,
uh,
I think the evolutionary explanation is not a problem,
but we have constructed a world where in most societies,
except for very unusual,
a polygamous societies,
uh,
the belief is that you can't,
you know,
you can't love more than one.
All right.
And,
uh,
so you've got this tension between what might be evolutionarily wired impulses
and a kind of social constraints that say,
this isn't good,
this is inappropriate,
this is taboo.
And,
um,
uh,
my guess the result is yes,
you could,
but you're not going to feel unconflicted about it.
And it's because these two are confronting each other at the same time.
How about one more question and then we'll let you go.
Sorry.
I saw him first.
Natural selection favored people,
all these things and then swipe,
like practically applied to,
so he's making the evolutionary argument.
Wouldn't natural selection favor the people who take introductory psychology,
come to my Valentine's Day lecture,
listened carefully to the big three on the more interesting for,
and then go out there and put them into practice.
It feels a little bit like the,
um,
like we're trying to pass on an acquired characteristic,
which is a little bit counter to Darwinian theory,
but if somehow,
you know,
if you could design a,
a,
a proclivity for learning this kind of material evolution might indeed favorite,
uh,
I could tell you this much,
it would make the several thousand social psychologists in this world very happy
and proud of their field if that turned out to be true.
Anyway,
thank you all very much.
Happy Valentine's Day.
Yeah.